[Música]
se estima que 1.2 billones de fotos han
sido tomadas el año pasado por teléfonos
inteligentes esto es más de 38 mil fotos
tomadas por cada segundo y que nos deja
conectarnos y compartir memorias con
nuestros seres queridos en cuestión de
segundos algo que antes era inimaginable
esta tecnología de las cámaras de los
teléfonos inteligentes algo que muchos
de nosotros utilizamos cada día fue
desarrollada para reducir el tamaño de
las cámaras de los vehículos espaciales
interplanetarios que tenían como
objetivo hacer observaciones de otros
planetas de nuestro sistema solar
hace más de 500 años muchos exploradores
fueron impulsados por la curiosidad de
descubrir mundos desconocidos hace más
de 100 años la curiosidad de albert
eisntein lo llevó a descubrir la teoría
de la relatividad y años después él dijo
yo no tengo ningún talento especial yo
sólo soy apasionadamente curioso lo que
nos enseña que la curiosidad nos ha
lanzado a poder atravesar los límites de
lo conocido
y así como hace cientos de años
decidimos explorar continentes y océanos
desconocidos
hoy en día decidimos explorar el espacio
a lo largo de nuestra historia y ahora
más en la actualidad los humanos estamos
atravesando diferentes desafíos como
enfermedades y cambios climáticos que
impactan nuestras vidas si comenzamos a
buscar soluciones para estos problemas
ya podemos comenzar a hablar acerca de
un mejor futuro para nuestra humanidad
el concepto de la exploración espacial
ha traído diferentes tecnologías que hoy
han salvado vidas y es esencial para el
futuro de la humanidad
reflejando lo que decía albert eisntein
nosotros los humanos somos curiosos y
eso nos ha llevado a ser más innovadores
y nos ha enseñado a poder ser más
proactivos como ver la manera más
eficiente de reaccionar ante un desastre
natural
por ejemplo en el año 1900
el huracán de galveston de categoría 4
impactó la costa de texas y por lo menos
8.000 personas fallecieron
en el 2017 el huracán
harvey también de categoría 4 impacto la
misma cosa
y miles de personas evacuaron sus
viviendas ya que fueron notificadas en
anticipación por información provista
por satélites en órbita
estos tipos de satélite pudieron salvar
vidas ya que se reportó que 80 personas
fallecieron esto es el 1 por ciento de
lo que se había visto hace 100 años y lo
que nos demuestra y nos enseña que esto
tiene este tipo de tecnologías nos está
ayudando a notificar a personas para que
puedan evacuar y salvarse esta misma
tecnología es utilizada para pronosticar
los tifones y los ciclones en todas
partes del mundo por otro lado el
colegio de medicina de la universidad de
mount sinai de nueva york
hizo un estudio en el 2010
donde comparó a dos grupos de personas
que habían sobrevivido el cáncer de
pulmón
uno de los grupos mostró que tuvo el 64
por ciento más de probabilidad de
sobrevivir
este grupo fue el que tuvo la tomografía
computarizada la tomografía
computarizada nos da imágenes de tres
dimensiones donde nos muestra identifica
anormalidades y tumores en pacientes
esto es muy importante y lo más
interesante es que esta tecnología fue
derivada de la técnica de procesamiento
de imágenes digitales que fue creada en
los 1960 para el programa espacial lunar
apollo
donde fue utilizada para identificar los
lugares donde a polo iba a aterrizar
la exploración espacial es compleja pero
no imposible y nos ha mostrado cómo ha
estado retando el potencial y la
habilidad humana
y también nos ha mostrado que no sólo es
cuestión de retarse pero cómo podemos
nosotros como humanos ayudar a la
humanidad
y como nace esto en mí de la exploración
espacial
yo nací acá en perú y vengo de una
familia de dos hermanos
donde mis padres nos enseñaron la
importancia de la educación el respeto y
la perseverancia en el 98 mi hermano mi
segundo hermano entró a la universidad
nacional de ingeniería la uni y obtuvo
su grado de ingeniería de sistemas esto
a mí me inspiró y abrió mis ojos a las
posibilidades que yo también podía ser
ingeniero
en el 2001 mis padres y yo me gramos a
eeuu
en el 2003 por primera vez vía
televisión puede ver el lanzamiento del
transbordador espacial columbia
esta fue la primera vez donde vi este
masivo vehículo propulsarse a más de
3.500 toneladas de fuerza
y en ese momento yo me pregunte cómo es
posible que este vehículo espacial haya
podido no así salir de nuestra atmósfera
[Aplausos]
yo estaba esperando que esta misión
vuelva de regreso a la tierra
lamentablemente hubo un accidente y
siete vidas fueron perdidas
en este momento me di cuenta de que
todavía hay mucho por hacer por la
humanidad y por la exploración espacial
y yo dije yo quiero ser parte de ese
equipo que evite de que eso vuelva a
pasar
la curiosidad y mi pasión por la
exploración espacial me llevó a
investigar oportunidades y después me
matriculé en una academia de ciencia
tecnología y matemáticas luego obtuve mi
grado de ingeniería aeroespacial de la
universidad de virginia tech y después
mi maestría de rice university donde
tuve la oportunidad de hacer diferentes
investigaciones con profesores y este
tipo de experiencia fue lo que me ayudó
grandemente a que cuando yo ya me estaba
graduando ya tenía ofertas de trabajo
mi primer trabajo fue como ingeniera
para el programa de la estación espacial
internacional y me enfoqué en los
análisis diseño y también las
operaciones de los mecanismos que son
mandados al espacio como los paneles
solares que provee electricidad a toda
la estación espacial internacional
mi cargo actual yo trabajo para nada
sacar world of fighters theory donde soy
manager de los vehículos espaciales
manejo las comunicaciones de los cohetes
que son mandados a órbita terrestre baja
a la estación espacial internacional y
esto es más o menos a 408 kilómetros
aquí es como en una distancia de lima a
nasca
en estos casi 10 años he tenido la
oportunidad de poder conocer todas las
diferentes herramientas que se están
haciendo
para la exploración espacial y nos está
ayudando grandemente aquí en la tierra
para mí es muy fascinante poder saber
que en este momento tenemos a un
laboratorio espacial orbitando la tierra
cada 90 minutos y que está orbitando la
tierra a una velocidad de 27 mil 600
kilómetros por hora
y que en este momento tenemos
astronautas que están trabajando y
haciendo investigaciones con diferentes
agencias espaciales internacionales y
que están trabajando con 103 países para
poder darnos a nosotros aquí a los
humanos diferentes tipos de medicina
tecnología y están en búsqueda de una
cura para el cáncer osteoporosis y
medicinas para para personas de alta
edad
a la misma vez yo pienso que todavía hay
mucho por explorar y hasta este momento
sólo hemos podido descubrir un fragmento
de nuestro universo es lo que es
importante es poder saber la importancia
de lo que se puede lograr en el espacio
y no aquí en la tierra por la ausencia
de la gravedad
por ejemplo aquí en la tierra tenemos la
gravedad lo que nos atrae hacia el suelo
y a veces no nos limita de una manera
que puede hacer ciertos experimentos
en el espacio como el como en la
estación estación internacional la
gravedad es mínima también llamada la
microgravedad
donde nos da la oportunidad de poder
hacer diferentes experimentos
cómo poder analizar la estructura
de las células cancerosas
ya que este ambiente nos da la
oportunidad de poder analizar y replicar
cómo estas células crecen y se
desarrollan y nos está abriendo las
puertas para poder en un futuro de
repente encontrar
un tratamiento para el cáncer
se imaginan ustedes no poder tener las
suficientes herramientas quirúrgicas
para poder tener una cirugía en este
momento tenemos a un brazo robótico
quirúrgico que fue derivado de la brazo
robótico que es utilizado en la estación
espacial internacional este brazo
robótico es utilizado para poder hacer
diferentes eventos espaciales como
levantar a un vehículo espacial y
acoplarlo a la estación espacial
internacional
y hasta este momento ha podido ayudar a
pacientes a hacer cirugías que necesitan
alta precisión
y apoyo ayudar a 70 de ellos que de otra
manera no hubiesen podido tener ningún
tipo de operación
y como también vemos la sesión espacial
internacional nos está ayudando en
diferentes maneras como diferentes
medicinas generar diferentes tecnologías
hacer observaciones de la tierra y cada
día se aprende algún nuevo
y cómo está perú en todo esto a quién
pero también estamos siendo testigos de
estos avances tecnológicos
si pensamos acerca de nuestra historia
la civilización incaica construyó
edificios y templos que han durado
terremotos por más de 500 años y también
tuvieron la sabiduría de poder construir
sistemas hidráulicos para transportar
agua a más de un kilómetro de distancia
en el 2016 el perú sat1 fue lanzado al
espacio
este es un satélite del gobierno peruano
que es manejado por la agencia espacial
peruana con iva
y que tiene como objetivo hacer
diferentes observaciones de la tierra y
obtener imágenes digitales de alta
definición para poder ayudar en la
minería en la pesca en la agricultura
el chasqui 1 fue lanzado durante una
caminata espacial desde la estación
espacial internacional
este nanosatélite fue hecho por
estudiantes de la universidad nacional
de ingeniería
y tuvo como objetivo hacer observaciones
en la tierra y también monitorear
nuestra amazonía y costa peruana
y también profundizar el conocimiento de
tecnologías aeroespaciales
y les comparto todo esto porque es
importante reflejar de nuestra historia
y también de los diferentes esfuerzos
que recientemente se han hecho para
generar más tecnología que ayude al perú
y el mundo en poder superar diferentes
problemas que están atravesando
imaginemos a un perú donde podemos
generar diferentes tecnologías para
ayudar nuestras propias carencias
a un país que está creciendo como
potencia en la región imaginémonos a un
perú que está tratando de superar sus
problemas cotidianos para poder
enfocarse en problemas más restantes
imaginémonos a un perú que inspira a sus
estudiantes a explorar en las materias
de ciencia tecnología ingeniería y
matemáticas imaginémonos sea un perú
donde las investigaciones son la norma y
no la excepción y donde se está haciendo
todas esas investigaciones con la
agencia espacial peruana y muchas
agencias espaciales internacionales
les invito a imaginar y hacer esto
realidad los invito a ser curiosos
para que puedan ser innovadores y les
reto a explorar
john f.kennedy una vez dijo hemos
decidido ir a la luna hemos decidido ir
a la luna en esta década y también
afrontar los otros desafíos no porque
sea fácil sino porque es difícil porque
esta meta nos ayudará para coordinar y
medir lo mejor de nuestras energías y
actitudes clases